[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 loisirs
vos idées sorties dans le département on
commence ensuite avec le sommaire ce
week-end se tient la 14e la 14e édition
d'art manet à montigny le bretonneux le
marché international de l'art
contemporain
fernand romeo le commissaire de
l'exposition nous rejoindra pour nous en
parler aux clayes-sous-bois les
adolescents travaillent sur la première
guerre mondiale pendant les vacances
miroir d'histoire un projet qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre du centenaire en
novembre la ville organisera plusieurs
événements à cette occasion enfin notre
chronique dédiée aux juniors il sera
question des championnats d'europe de
cyclisme sur piste au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui se
tiennent jusqu'à dimanche
michael almy d'euros nous donnera
quelques pistes pour faire découvrir
cette discipline aux enfants ça ne vous
a pas échappé les vacances de la
toussaint ont débuté ce mercredi
cette occasion le château de breteuil
mais le goût à l'honneur jusqu'au 2
novembre au cours de la visite guidée un
jeu sur le thème est proposé aux enfants
avec un questionnaire à remplir tous les
jours à 16h30 la conteuse racontera
aussi trois histoires dont une
spécialement sur le goût dimanche un
rendez vous particulier est prévu il
s'agit de la soupe de compte
henri-françois de breteuil nous donne la
recette dans la soupe des comptes on a
trois sortes de souple que l'on veut
décrire en fait ce sont des contes où
l'on rencontre le thème de la soupe
alors il ya d'abord la soupe bien sûr au
potiron ou la soupe au bouillon de poule
ensuite il ya la soupe du chat 28 ce ça
va très bien pour le chat botté au
château de breteuil et puis la dernière
soupe c'est la soupe à la grimace
à l'occasion du centenaire de la
première guerre mondiale les
clayes-sous-bois organise plusieurs
manifestations à partir du 5 novembre
expositions spectacles mais aussi un
projet miroir d'histoire
les jeunes de cap ados réalise plusieurs
travaux d'écriture et de photographies
nous les avons suivis en pleine
réflexion
dans les tranchées l'odeur de la mort
règne les rats nous envahissent les
parasites nous ronge la peau nous vivons
dans la boue une lettre rédigée à verdun
lors de la première guerre mondiale
c'est avec ce support que travaille huit
adolescents des clayes-sous-bois encadré
par un écrivain la liberté et la douceur
l'idée c'est de voir quelle quelle
lettre les générations d'aujourd'hui
pourrait écrire aux poilus qui était
dans les tranchées qui faisait la guerre
de 14 18
donc ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui dans
une première étape de travail c'est
faire un brainstorming pour dégager des
mots clés des grandes idées miroir
d'histoire un projet mené dans le cadre
du centenaire de la première guerre
mondiale pour sensibiliser les
participants
en parallèle de cette lettre et avec
l'aide d'un photographe le luan et
margot réalise un diaporama
on a posé sur une feuille des idées des
mots en rapport avec notre thème et via
photo on va essayer de transmettre avec
des images j'ai très envie de pleurer
parce que c'est quand même une aide très
très très très belle après ça tombe dans
l'oubli et c'est dommage que de telles
choses tombent dans l'oubli après tout
ce que mes soldats
on paie cher pour nous les adolescents
jusqu'à la fin des vacances pour
terminer leurs travaux ils doivent
encore enregistrer leurs lettres sur un
fond musical
en novembre la ville organise une série
d'événements autour du centenaire
le public pourra découvrir leurs
réalisations lors de la soirée de
lancement à l'espace philippe noiret je
vous le disais en titre la 14e édition
d'art manette débute dès demain jusqu'à
dimanche les visiteurs sont invités à
découvrir le travail de 52 artistes à la
ferme du mas net de montigny le
bretonneux avec nous faire non romeo
commissaire de cette exposition bonjour
merci d'être venu sur notre plateau est
ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un peu
plus sur cet événement vous faites
partie du lait du lion's club montini
des trois villages qui organisent
armanet chaque année absolument et c'est
la quatorzième édition cette année 14e
édition qui j'espère sera aussi bonne
que l'an dernier
donc comme vous l'avez vous le dites
nous allons accueillir plus de 50
artistes sculpteurs photographes et
peintres de tous genres et donc je vous
invite à venir le plus le plus de monde
possible pour participer à cette
manifestation
alors vous avez dit justement des
sculpteurs des peintres des photographes
quel artiste est ce qu'on pourra
retrouver ce que vous avez quelques
petits noms à nous donner nous vous
donnons nous avons pas dans un sculpteur
qui vient et qui est un habitué de
harman qui les sculpteurs sur bois sur
pièce sur faire et d'ailleurs lors de
cette manifestation il participera
effectivement à une affaire sa sculpture
en direct lors de ce nom en direct les
visites devant des visiteurs et les
visiteurs du coup ils peuvent soit venir
en visite libre regardait mais ils
peuvent aussi acheter
absolument l'entrée est libre l'entrée
tout être totalement libre et puisse
donc les visiteurs peuvent acheter donc
une oeuvre qui leur fait qu'il leur fait
plaisir bien entendu sachez que tous les
oeuvres vendues le lion ce club ne
récolte pas d'argent par contre nous
pouvons effectivement aux artistes alors
qu'un stand et toute la somme que nous
récoltons suite à cette cet argent
récolté est reversé pour la maladie
d'alzheimer le handicap ou la
maltraitance
donc c'est justement pour des actions
tous les bénéfices sont reversés pour
des actions solidaires
est ce que vous nous en dire un peu plus
sur les partenariats vous est notamment
partenaire c'est reversés à
l'association france à la structure
française la france alzheimer le husky
où on reverse des sommes de façon à
aménager des maisons de jour pour les
aidants nous travaillons aussi avec le
chr l'équinoxe est un sel pour les
femmes les femmes battues battu voilà
donc aussi nous avons aussi un
partenariat avec la ffr t 78 sur le
handicap est sûre
la trisomie 21 sur la trisomie 21
également l'autisme l'autisme aussi nous
avons énormément travaillé sur ce sujet
là et nous avons donné un certain nombre
de ceux d'argent seul alors et justement
alors pour revenir un petit peu aux
sommes que vous avez réussi à collecter
notamment l'an dernier qu'elle savait ce
que vous avez réussi à avoir
l'an dernier nous avons nous avons
réussi à récolter plus de 6000 euros
somme qui a été entièrement
redistribuées donc à toutes ces
associations et nous espérons faire au
moins aussi bien c'est pour moi autant
que je voulais dire aussi c'est que nous
organisons aussi à nous mettons aussi
une tombola et il est le les gens
peuvent gagner une oeuvre donc moyennant
à ce jeu de tombola dont peu 2 euros
peuvent repartir avec une langue de leur
choix
d'accord mais j'ai de dépenser des
centaines d'euros au départ contre
n'hésitez pas à acheter parce que les
artistes viennent aussi pour vendre très
bien un dernier petit mot sur le lannion
ce club quelles sont vos actions en
dehors de cette exposition a donc le
lion's-club montigné les trois villages
le jeu appelle qui est montigny voisins
et guyancourt
nous avons aussi au delà de harman et
une no trace une autre manifestation qui
hélas prairial qui ce qui ce lieu au
mois d'avril
donc là principalement c'est la fête des
fleurs et c'est pour l'aide aux écoles
de chute de 10 de chiens guides est
aveugle
voilà nous avons aussi une autre
manifestation qui est le théâtre avec le
partenariat de du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ou cinq ans le
théâtre nous vendait des places moitié
prix nous leur vendons bien entendu pris
entier donc au même prix que le théâtre
est toute la somme récoltée reversés
pour les enfants malades de la leucémie
ou d'un cancer avons toujours des
actions se libéra merci beaucoup
enfin dans roméo d'être venu sur notre
plateau pour parler de cet événement
armanet on le répète armanet se déroule
ce week end à la ferme du manet et c'est
une entrée libre merci ferme romeo merci
à lui alors si vous n'êtes pas trop
branché armes est plutôt logique il est
passionné d'échecs ont également
rendez-vous à montigny le bretonneux dès
demain pour le 15e tournoi d'automne du
club de la dame noire un événement
ouvert à tous quel que soit son niveau
en parallèle est organisé le troisième
tournoi international de mettre les
meilleurs joueurs français et
internationaux vont
s'affronter et de tournoi commence
demain jusqu'au 30 octobre on écoute
l'un des membres du bureau du club de la
dame noire il était au micro de nicolas
kirilow dit c'est fait pour tout le
monde jeunes si ce n'est de dessus
notamment auprès des parents s'il y en a
qui nous écoutent
inscrivez vos enfants aux échecs c'est
fait pour tout le monde chacun pourra
jouer de façon très intéressante en
fonction de ce niveau et sa demande pas
de qualités particulières faut être faut
se concentrer et puis c'est tout à
partir de lundi la royale factory de
versailles programme un spectacle
musical et familial
soum l'ami des fantômes un conte pour
petits et grands qui mêle intrigue
chansons et humour il raconte l'histoire
de soumah personnage vous moquez par les
gens de son village
il devra pourtant les sauver de monstres
qui les envahissent une aventure
politique qui traite de la différence et
du respect de l'autre
elle est programmée tous les jours 14
enfants du 28 octobre ou regardent en
extra
[Musique]
non
ouais
[Applaudissements]
un prix
comme chaque vendredi nous vous
proposons une chronique spéciale pour
les juniors aujourd'hui notre
journaliste sportif michael et demi
d'euros est avec nous en plateau pour
nous parler des championnats d'europe de
cyclisme sur piste bonjour michael
bonjour camille j'espère que vous allez
bien depuis la semaine dernière est bien
alors vous disiez a précédemment je vais
vous parler des championnats d'europe de
cyclisme sur piste la compétition a
débuté à ce mercredi se poursuivra
jusqu'à ce dimanche au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
vous allez me dire mais quel est le
rapport avec la chronique junior mickaël
je vous réponde camille cette deuxième
compétition internationale organisée à
part le vélodrome après les championnats
du monde 2015 à dire beaucoup de jeunes
et en particulier des enfants comme on
peut le voir sur cette séquence fait
impressionné et j'ai surtout vu ça à la
télé d'habitude mais je suis
impressionné la vitesse le fait qui
passe juste à côté ne serait peut-être
pas venu ici à l'épaule les enfants
parce que c'est lui qui m'a un petit peu
a incité ce soir à venir c'est une
sortie en famille oui parce que je
réponds les jeunes ils veulent voir un
petit peu les sports on a la chance
d'avoir un vélo breuer a 50 ans
c'est l'objet de notre venue ici ce soir
ainsi que ça change parce que d'habitude
on parle des matchs de foot du rugby et
n'était jamais allé alors ça va tu as
et si vous n'êtes toujours pas convaincu
je vais vous donner trois raisons pour
venir au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin et minent ce week-end avec
vos enfants
c'est un championnat d'europe c'est un
événement spectaculaire imaginer un vélo
lancé à plus de 60 kilomètres heure sur
une piste de 250 mètres de long avec sur
les côtés une pente à 45 degrés notre
consultant à eagan dujarrier en est
persuadé les enfants adorent ce sport
est en effet c'est un spectacle qui est
facile à partager avec avec ses avec ses
enfants
à partir d'un certain âge quand ils ont
la patience de pouvoir attendre quelques
heures parce que un spectacle qui se
renouvelle que
pourtant mai mais qui dure qui dure
quand même un bon moment et c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose qui se partager
les enfants généralement aime beaucoup
parce qu'il ya une usine communion avec
avec le public avec l'electricite m bala
vitesse et après j'aime bien les virages
caen s'est incliné
[Musique]
c'est très pentu et à la télé ne dirais
pas que c'est que c'est comme ça alors
on peut dire que vous avez à marquer un
point michael on passe maintenant à
notre deuxième raison est effectivement
les championnats d'europe offre
également la possibilité aux enfants de
voir d'autres nations aux étrangères
c'est un petit peu un cours de
géographie à accélérer camille il y a à
28 pays sur cette compétition on
retrouve les meilleures nations de
l'europe la grande bretagne qui a
triomphé lors des derniers jo de rio
l'italie la russie ou encore l'allemagne
mais on peut également voir des pays un
petit peu moins connus comme la
biélorussie ou la slovaquie
en tout cas les sportifs sont tous ravis
d'être ici nous les avons rencontrés
incroyable c'est aussi très bien d'être
encore en france oui j'aime bien la
langue
j'aimerais bien aussi
la france en général comme ça c'est trop
bien d'être ici je pense que c'est
vraiment très bien d'être ici
j'aime bien la piste c'est vraiment très
sympa c'est un gros événement surtout
quoi fine toujours regarder vers le
futur
alors il n'y a pas que les nations
étrangères michael il ya aussi et
surtout l'équipe de france oui on arrive
au troisième point est sûrement le plus
important camille l'équipe de france est
en opération reconquête après le fiasco
des jo de rio avec une seule médaille de
bronze
la fédération a lancé à des petits
jeunes sur la piste l'équipe de france
d'endurance qui a remporté l'or hier
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
et emmenés par un trappistes benjamin
thomas qui à tout juste 21 ans et
florian m 19 ans la génération qui sera
aux jo de 2024 en france les enfants
adorent les champions camille et ses
garçons le seront sûrement pour les
prochains jo de 2024 qui seront peut
être organisée à paris en écoute vincent
jacquet le dtn de l'équipe de france il
nous parle justement de cette jeune
génération
c'est un bel avantage puisque ça veut
dire qu'on a de la réserve
ça veut dire que derrière on a toute une
génération qu'on souhaite accompagner à
grandir et derrière à petit à petit la
guérir assez assez grande compétition
internationale
alors si on veut voir cette belle équipe
de france le tarif est de 11 euros pour
les enfants et de 18 euros pour les
adultes
si vous habitez à saint quentin en
yvelines vous pouvez bénéficier d'un
tarif réduit il vous suffit juste de
venir à l'accueil du vélodrome avec un
justificatif de domicile
j'y vais ce week-end camille vous me
croyez pas peut-être michael le voir en
fonction de mon agenda en tout cas merci
beaucoup pour cette idée sortie pour les
juniors mais cette pique loisirs en tout
cas c'est terminé je vous retrouve
vendredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
très bon week-end à tous
[Musique]